microsoft revealed that falta horizon 3  is coming to Xbox one and PC and it's  set in Australia the game will offer up  a number of environments including  suburban areas desert of flooded plains  and the Microsoft showcase included a  downtown section with an elevated train  alongside your traditional vehicles and  gorgeous high powered cars for two  horizon 3 also features off-road racing  buggies and other new vehicle types the  game is also slated to include more  vehicles than any previous horizon game  4 player instant campaign co-op was also  announced for the game which should let  you easily join up with friends to race  alongside each other horizon 3 is due  out September 27 for both xbox one and  pc and the game will include  cross-platform play let me know if  you're keen for this one and stay tuned  to games but for all the latest